Before we get started, just a quick note. Our story this week is about the aftermath of a wildfire in Northern California. As we were putting the final touches on this episode, a new wildfire started burning in the same region where our story takes place. The Park Fire is one of the largest wildfires in California history and has displaced thousands of people. It won't be a major part of our story today, but we wanted to say here at the outset that our hearts are with the people of Butte County
在我开始之前，先简单说明一下。我们这周的故事关于北加州一场野火之后的余波。就在我们为本期节目做最后润色时，我们故事发生的那片区域又燃起了一场新的野火。“帕克大火”（Park Fire）是加州历史上最大的野火之一，已导致数千人流离失所。它不会成为我们今天故事的主要部分，但我们想在开篇表达：我们的心与比尤特县（Butte County）的人民同在，
and the surrounding area, who are once again struggling with the impacts of a mega fire and all that will come after it. Okay, here's episode two of Not Built For This, The Ripple Effect. At a city council meeting in Chico, California, in October of 2018, a man named Peter walked up to the podium. He was wearing a black tank top, and he seemed frustrated.
以及周边地区的人们，他们再次面临特大火灾及其后续一切影响的挣扎。好的，这里是《非为此而建》（Not Built For This）第二集：多米诺效应（The Ripple Effect）。2018年10月，在加州奇科（Chico）市议会的一次会议上，一个名叫彼得（Peter）的男子走到了讲台前。他穿着一件黑色背心，看起来十分沮丧。
I've been looking for housing, looking for housing, looking for housing. I have tried. I've gone through behavioral health. I've gone through 2-1-1. I've gone through behavioral health, I've gone through 2-1-1, I've gone through the housing authority, give me all these lists. All it does is waste my time because it's a list of apartments either I don't qualify for or they're already rented. He was almost shaking by this point, trying to convey just how hard he'd been trying to find a place to live. Every Monday I get them at 9 o'clock and I call you and it's already gone. Are you freaking kidding me?
我一直在找房子，找房子，找房子。我试过了。我找过行为健康部门，我找过2-1-1，我找过行为健康部门，我找过2-1-1，我找过房屋管理局，给了我所有这些名单。这全是在浪费我的时间，因为上面的公寓要么我不符合资格，要么就已经租出去了。说到这里，他几乎在颤抖，试图表达他为了找个住处付出了多大的努力。每周一我9点拿到名单然后给他们打电话，房子就已经没了。你们是在开玩笑吗？
I live in this field between Walmart and that car lot. But Peter was not telling the people on the Chico City Council anything that they did not already know. It was obvious to anyone who was paying attention that the city, really the entire county, was having a very hard time keeping roofs over people's heads. There was very little housing opportunity, in fact no effective housing opportunity for lower income households. Ed Mayer is the former executive director of the Butte County Housing Authority.
我住在沃尔玛和那个停车场之间的这块空地上。但彼得并没有向奇科市议会的人透露任何他们原本不知道的事情。任何留心观察的人都显而易见地发现，这座城市，确切地说是整个县，在为人们提供遮身之所方面遇到了极大的困难。几乎没有什么住房机会，实际上对于中低收入家庭来说，根本没有有效的住房机会。埃德·迈耶（Ed Mayer）是比尤特县住房管理局的前执行董事。
He was actually the person in charge of giving vouchers to people like Peter. And he knew full well that there was hardly anything for them to use those vouchers on. We saw a lot of elderly coming in and we saw a lot of homeless coming in that we just were unable to help at all. So the situation was dire. Do you remember the vacancy rate by any chance? Most housing experts agree that a healthy rental vacancy rate
他实际上是那个负责向像彼得这样的人发放住房券（vouchers）的人。他心里很清楚，他们几乎没有什么地方可以用这些券。我们看到很多老年人涌入，也看到很多无家可归者涌入，而我们根本无能为力。所以情况非常严峻。你还记得当时的空置率吗？大多数住房专家认为，健康的住房租赁空置率
is somewhere between six and 8%. I think the effective vacancy rate was half percent or below. It was that bad. I've never seen a housing market in my career that bad. I've never seen a housing market in my career that bad. There were not enough homes to buy or rent or even shelter beds to crash for a night. You could be forgiven for thinking that things couldn't get any worse. But that would be wrong because Butte County was about to lose a massive chunk of its most affordable housing stock.
大约在百分之六到百分之八之间。我认为当时的实际空置率在半个百分点或以下。情况就是这么糟。在我职业生涯中，我从未见过如此糟糕的住房市场。在我职业生涯中，我从未见过如此糟糕的住房市场。没有足够的房屋可供买卖或租赁，甚至连供人借宿一晚的庇护所床位都没有。你可能会以为事情不会再变得更糟了。但那就大错特错了，因为比尤特县即将失去其最可负担住房存量中的很大一部分。
It was about to lose the entire town of Paradise. Starting on November 8th of 2018, an enormous wildfire began ripping through the forested foothills around Paradise. Wildfires are often named for the nearest road from which they were first reported. This fire started off of Camp Creek Road, which gave it a spectacularly understated name, the Camp Fire. The Camp Fire is the deadliest and most destructive wildfire in California's history. As the fire burned paradise to the ground, Ed was at his office in Chico, about 15 miles away.
它即将失去天堂镇（Paradise）整个镇子。从2018年11月8日开始，一场巨大的野火开始在天堂镇周围的森林山麓中肆虐。野火通常以它们首次被报告时最近的道路来命名。这场火灾起于坎普克里克路（Camp Creek Road），这给它起了一个极其轻描淡写的名字——坎普大火（Camp Fire）。坎普大火是加州历史上致死人数最多、最具破坏性的野火。当大火将天堂镇烧为平地时，埃德正在大约15英里外的奇科办公室里。
He was trying to get a handle on just how many homes had been lost throughout the county. At some point, he got an email from a colleague estimating 14,000. And I went, oh my goodness, and I thought 14,000, and I roughly did the math very quickly in my head. Number of people per household, three people per household, that's 45,000. Somewhere between 35,000, 45,000 people have been displaced. I burst into tears.
他试图弄清楚整个县究竟有多少房屋被毁。在某个时刻，他收到了一位同事的电子邮件，估计有14000栋。我说，哦，天哪，我想象着14000栋，然后在脑子里非常快地大致算了一下。每户的人数，每户三个人，那就是45,000人。有三万五千到四万五千人流离失所。我当场失声痛哭。
The fire was contained after a couple of weeks, but Ed's problems were just beginning. He had already been struggling to find housing for the most vulnerable people in the county. How on earth was he supposed to conjure up homes for the 45,000 people who had suddenly been made homeless? To be in a business where housing was that difficult to start, and then to have that kind of thing hit your community was just, it was brutal. Someday, we'll probably be able to see clear trends
大火在几周后得到了控制，但埃德的麻烦才刚刚开始。他之前就已经在为县里最脆弱的人群寻找住房而苦苦挣扎了。他到底该怎么凭空为那45,000名突然无家可归的人变出住所呢？从事一个本来找房就已经如此艰难的行业，然后又遭遇这种打击降临到你的社区，这简直是……太残酷了。总有一天，我们或许能清晰地看出
in climate migration. Over time, it's likely that millions of people will move northward and away from the coasts. But the reality right now is much more chaotic. Most people aren't migrating intentionally. They're being displaced by escalating fires and floods and extreme storms. And then they have to figure out where to go in a housing landscape that is often not ready to receive them.
气候移民的趋势。随着时间的推移，很可能会有数百万人向北迁移，远离海岸。但现实情况要混乱得多。大多数人并非有意迁移，而是被不断升级的野火、洪水和极端风暴逼得流离失所。然后，他们必须在一个往往没有准备好接纳他们的住房市场中寻找出路。
Most of the stories about the Camp Fire have understandably focused on Paradise, the beloved town with the iconic name that was nearly wiped off the map. But the nearby city of Chico was also transformed by the fire. Because in disasters where a lot of people lose their homes, the impacts are not contained to a single city or town. They ripple outward, cascading into the surrounding area, as the survivors are forced to go looking for new places to live. This is the story of what happened after the famous fire in Paradise.
关于坎普大火的大多数报道，情有可原，都聚焦于天堂镇——那个名字深入人心、几乎从地图上被抹去的挚爱小镇。但附近的奇科市也因这场大火而发生了翻天覆地的变化。因为在许多人失去家园的灾难中，影响并不仅仅局限于某个单一的城市或城镇。随着幸存者被迫去寻找新的居住地，这些影响向外扩散，层层波及到周边地区。这就是天堂镇那场著名大火之后所发生的故事。
It's about two women from very different economic backgrounds, struggling in very different ways to find a place to live in the aftermath of disaster. And it's about a town caught in the crosshairs of both the climate crisis and the housing crisis. And how the people there reacted when thousands of displaced climate migrants showed up on their doorstep. Because Chico, California was not built for this.
它讲述了两位来自截然不同经济背景的女性，在灾难过后以截然不同的方式挣扎着寻找住处的故事。这也关于一个小镇，它同时陷入了气候危机和住房危机的交火中心。以及当成千上万流离失所的气候难民出现在他们的家门口时，当地人是如何反应的。因为加州奇科根本不是为此而建的。
I'm Emmett Fitzgerald. this. I'm Emmett Fitzgerald. Chico is a small city at the edge of California's Central Valley, where the northern Sierra foothills meet the flat agricultural plains. It's a relatively wealthy college town in a relatively poor farming county. Summers in Chico are hot and getting hotter every year. But there are all these creeks that run right through the center of town where people can cool off. Chico has a yo-yo museum,
我是埃姆特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）。此。我是埃姆特·菲茨杰拉德。奇科是加州中央谷地（Central Valley）边缘的一座小城，北部的内华达山脉山麓（Sierra foothills）在这里与平坦的农业平原交汇。在一个相对贫穷的农业县里，这是一个相对富裕的大学城。奇科的夏天很热，而且每年都在变得更热。但镇中心有许多小溪穿城而过，人们可以在那里消暑。奇科有一个溜溜球（yo-yo）博物馆，
a really high number of breweries per capita, and a bustling farmers market where you can buy a beaded bracelet from a white lady with dreadlocks or locally grown pomegranates. When I first came to Chico, I thought I had died and gone to heaven. It had everything. I mean, I loved the community. The music was insane. I mean, I just loved it. Susan Dobre came to Chico in the 90s to teach in the English department at Chico State.
人均精酿啤酒厂数量极高，还有一个繁华的农贸市场，你可以在那里从一个带着长 dreadlocks（脏辫）的白人女性手里买到串珠手链，或者买到当地种植的石榴。我刚来奇科时，以为自己死后进了天堂。这里应有尽有。我是说，我爱这里的社区。音乐太疯狂了。我是说，我简直爱死这里了。苏珊·多布雷（Susan Dobre）在90年代来到奇科，在奇科州立大学（Chico State）的英语系教书。
The job didn't end up working out, but she stuck around because she loved the city so much. She met a skinny guitar player named John Michael, and she moved in with him and his son, Skyler. John Michael and I, at that point, you know, we were raising Skyler, we had fallen in love, we decided to try to buy a house together. So we went looking and couldn't find anything in Chico
这份工作最后没能持续下去，但她留了下来，因为她太喜欢这座城市了。她遇到了一位名叫约翰·迈克尔（John Michael）的瘦高吉他手，并搬去和他以及他的儿子斯凯勒（Skyler）一起居住。当时我和约翰·迈克尔，你知道的，我们在抚养斯凯勒，我们坠入爱河，决定尝试一起买栋房子。于是我们开始寻找，但在奇科找不到任何
that we could afford. Housing in Chico was pricey even back then. And so historically, a lot of people who worked in Chico would live about 20 minutes outside of town up on the ridge in smaller, more affordable communities like Concau, Megalia and Paradise. When we went up to Paradise and found out that literally the houses were like a hundred thousand000 cheaper than in Chico.
我们买得起的房子。那时的奇科住房就已经价格不菲了。因此，从历史来看，许多在奇科工作的人会住在距离镇外大约20分钟车程、位于山脊上更小、更经济实惠的社区，比如孔考（Concau）、梅加利亚（Megalia）和天堂镇。当我们去到天堂镇，发现那里的房子实际上比奇科便宜十万美元左右。
And we started looking up there. This is a common story throughout California. As the cost of living has soared, people have gotten pushed out of expensive cities and into the forested hills outside of town. And in the mid-2000s, Susan and John Michael found an affordable fixer-upper in Paradise. You know, we love that house and we put so much into it, so much love into it, and so much to see it go from the crap that it was to the beautiful house that we made it into. John Michael's a genius contractor.
然后我们开始在那儿找房。这是加州各地常见的故事。随着生活成本飙升，人们被挤出了昂贵的城市，来到了城外的森林山麓。2000年代中期，苏珊和约翰·迈克尔在天堂镇找到了一处价格实惠、需要装修的房子。你知道，我们爱那座房子，我们在它上面倾注了那么多心血，倾注了那么多爱，看到它从破烂不堪变成我们打造的美丽家园，真的感慨万千。约翰·迈克尔是个天才建筑承包商。
Susan and John Michael lived in that house for over a decade, and they made a life for themselves up on the ridge. They found friends through the Paradise Grange, an old venue in town that hosted concerts and open mic nights. They liked living in paradise. Even though there wasn't a lot of racial diversity, there were people from very different classes and cultures living side by side.
苏珊和约翰·迈克尔在那栋房子里住了十多年，在山脊上过上了属于自己的生活。他们通过天堂镇格兰奇（Paradise Grange）结交了朋友，那是一个镇上的老旧活动场所，举办音乐会和开放麦之夜。他们喜欢住在天堂镇。尽管这里的种族多样性并不丰富，但不同阶层和文化背景的人们比邻而居。
Ranchers and hippies, artists and weed farmers, people who had just bought their first home, and people who had nowhere else to go. Like Crystal Johnson. I think people live up there for the serenity of life. The serenity of the hills, the nature. That's where my serenity was. Crystal Johnson moved up to the ridge in 2017,
牧场主和嬉皮士、艺术家和大麻种植者、刚刚买下第一套房的人，以及无处可去的人。比如克里斯塔尔·约翰逊（Crystal Johnson）。我认为人们住在那里是为了生活的宁静。山脊的宁静，大自然。那就是我的宁静所在。克里斯塔尔·约翰逊于2017年搬到了山脊上，
and her situation was very different from Susan's. Before that, she had been homeless for a bit, after losing an apartment that she shared with her ailing mom. She was not in a great place and needed a reset. Honestly, I went up there to go find myself, to find out what my purpose is and what I should be doing next
她的情况与苏珊截然不同。在此之前，她在失去与生病的母亲合租的一间公寓后，曾流落街头一段时间。她的处境不太好，需要重新开始。说实话，我上山是为了寻找自我，找出我的人生目标以及接下来我该做什么，
and maybe get my shit together and go back to school or get my teeth done. Crystal got a job at a trailer park not far from paradise. She says she worked as an on-site manager, kind of like a super, and in exchange she got a free place to live. She spent her day cutting firewood for the residents and handling a seemingly endless stream of maintenance requests. It was busy, busy, busy.
也许是振作起来重回学校，或者把牙齿治好。克里斯塔尔在离天堂镇不远的一个房车公园找到了一份工作。她说她担任现场经理，有点像管理员（super），作为回报，她得到了一个免费的住处。她每天为居民砍柴，处理似乎永远也处理不完的维修请求。工作忙个不停。
There was no rest for me. But it made her happy. She found a sense of purpose working at the park. It felt good to have her own needs taken care of and be able to focus on helping other people. It just made my heart feel whole, like the Grinch, when he had that little tiny heart and it grew so big. For Crystal, the free housing and the job at the trailer park provided a crucial platform
我没有一刻休息。但这也让她感到快乐。她在公园的工作中找到了目标感。能照顾好自己的需求，又能专注于帮助其他人，这种感觉真好。这让我的心感到充实，就像《格林奇》里那样，当他那颗小小的心变得无比巨大时。对克里斯塔尔来说，免费的住房和房车公园的工作为她提供了一个至关重要的
of stability that she'd been struggling to find. And by 2018, it felt like her life was finally moving in the right direction. Meanwhile, Susan Dobre was still living in paradise with John Michael. She was commuting back down the hill into Chico to teach a class on global issues at the university. And one of the first units that she organized that year was on climate change. And I really, I have to admit, the strange thing was that I was thinking of it as a future problem at that time, you know, because it was like in 50 years, this is what's going
稳定平台，而她之前一直在为寻找这样的平台而苦苦挣扎。到2018年，她觉得生活终于朝着正确的方向前进了。与此同时，苏珊·多布雷仍然和约翰·迈克尔住在天堂镇。她每天通勤下山到奇科，在大学里教一门关于全球问题的课程。那一年她组织的第一批单元课程之一就是关于气候变化的。说实话，我必须承认，奇怪的是，当时我把它当成了一个未来的问题来考虑，你知道的，因为就像是再过50年才会发生的事，
to happen. And if we don't do this by 2050, it was kind of very oriented towards, you know, what was going to happen down the line. But then climate change got a lot more present tense. You know, it just kind of came roaring up to my back door. Fire is a natural part of the landscape of Northern California. And for centuries, indigenous people used fire intentionally to manage the forests of the Sierra Foothills and reduce the buildup of dead material. But in the 20th century, these cultural burning practices were replaced with the aggressive
如果我们到2050年还不这样做，它在很大程度上是面向未来的，你知道的，看未来会发生什么。但后来，气候变化变得更有“现在时”的紧迫感了。你知道，它就像是咆哮着来到了我的后门。火灾是北加州自然生态的一部分。几个世纪以来，原住民有意使用火来管理内华达山脉山麓的森林，并减少枯死植物的堆积。但在20世纪，这些文化烧荒实践被美国林务局激进的
fire suppression tactics of the US Forest Service. This resulted in forests that were essentially filled with kindling that was ready to burn. And then you add climate change to the equation. All across the Western US were seeing a growing number of days in a given year that have the right conditions for extreme fire. And a lot of these new fire weather days
灭火策略所取代。这导致森林里基本上充满了随时准备燃烧的引火物。然后你把气候变化这个因素加进去。整个美国西部，一年中具备极端火灾条件的日数都在不断增加。而许多这些新的火灾天气日
are happening in the late fall. Typically, Northern California can expect a good soaking rain by November, which effectively brings an end to that year's fire danger. But in 2018, the first winter storms were stubbornly behind schedule. And following one of the hottest summers on record, the landscape was kiln dry.
都发生在深秋。通常情况下，北加州到11月就会迎来一场透雨，这实际上宣告了当年火灾危险的结束。但在2018年，第一场冬季风暴却顽固地迟到了。在经历了一个有记录以来最炎热的夏天之后，这里的地表干燥得像一座窑炉。
How aware of wildfire as an issue were you in Paradise? Yeah, we were very aware we thought. Firerisk was not some great secret in Paradise. The town wasn't on the edge of the forest. It was built right among the dug firs and the ponderosa pines. But Susan and John Michael were never particularly stressed about fire. Their house wasn't at the end of some back country dirt road.
你在天堂镇时对野火这个问题有多大意识？是的，我们以为自己很有意识。火灾风险在天堂镇并不是什么天大的秘密。小镇并不在森林边缘，而是直接建在道格拉斯冷杉和黄松之间。但苏珊和约翰·迈克尔从未对火灾感到特别焦虑。他们的房子不在什么偏远乡村土路的尽头。
They had neighbors all around them, and they felt a false sense of suburban safety. A couple of weeks before the fire, we said, it's never going to get to us. We're in a neighborhood. They had actually just gone to a fire safety workshop at the Paradise Grange, where they learned all about the town's evacuation protocol.
他们的四周都是邻居，这让他们产生了一种虚假的郊区安全感。在大火发生前几周，我们还说过，火永远烧不到我们这里。我们在一个居民区里。他们实际上刚刚去参加了天堂镇格兰奇举办的消防安全研讨会，在那里他们了解了该镇的所有疏散方案。
They learned that in order to control traffic, every neighborhood had been given a zone. And on the day, if the fire happened, you're supposed to turn on your emergency radio station and wait for your zone to be called. You know, there was a plan. The campfire erupted on the morning of November 8th. It was a classic fire weather day with a hot, dry, ominous wind whipping down off the western slope of
他们了解到，为了控制交通，每个居民区都被划分了一个区域。到了那一天，如果发生火灾，你应该打开紧急广播电台，等待呼叫你们的区域。你知道，当时是有计划的。坎普大火于11月8日早晨爆发。那是一个典型的火灾天气日，一股炎热、干燥、不祥的风从内华达山脉西坡呼啸而下。苏珊那天一大早去看医生，当她下车时，看到停车场里有一群人正指着天空。
the Sierras. Susan had gone to a doctor's appointment early that morning and when she got out of her car she saw a bunch of people in the parking lot pointing at the sky. And there's a big glow in the sky like bigger than any like a sunrise right there's a big glow and I said, is that a fire? They said, yeah. I said, well, wow, that's big. And they said, yeah, and it's windy. Yeah. Earlier that morning, a piece of equipment
天空中有一道巨大的红光，比任何日出都要巨大，那里有一道巨大的红光，我说，那是火吗？他们说，是的。我说，哇，好大啊。他们说，对啊，风还很大。是的。那天早些时候，电力公司太平洋天然气和电力公司（PG&E）的一台设备
belonging to the power company PG&E had malfunctioned near the town of Polga. It sparked a small blaze, but it didn't take long for the 30 mile an hour winds to whip up an inferno. When she got home, Susan turned on the radio. This is an emergency notification for the town of Paradise.
在波尔加镇（Polga）附近发生故障。它引发了一场小火，但在每小时30英里的风力助长下，没过多久就变成了一场冲天大火。回到家后，苏珊打开了收音机。这是针对天堂镇的紧急通知。
The voice on the radio said that they were evacuating certain neighborhoods in Paradise, but not her zone. Zones one, five, 12, 15 are to be evacuated. Please stand by for other zones. But then she noticed that her next door neighbors were leaving in their RV. And they couldn't get out onto the road. And that's the first time I noticed, wow, there's traffic.
收音机里的声音说，他们正在疏散天堂镇的某些区域，但没有她的区域。1区、5区、12区、15区请撤离。请等待其他区域的通知。但随后她注意到她的隔壁邻居正在开着他们的房车离开。而且他们无法开上大路。那是她第一次注意到，哇，有车流。
There's traffic, there's a line of traffic on the road. And just then the electricity went off. Susan turned on her car radio so she could keep listening as they got ready to leave. And that's the first time I realized and noticed that I turned it on at 8 o'clock. It's now 11.15. This is the same message that's been playing. Zones 1, 5, 12, 15 are to be evacuated. Please stand by for other zones. The emergency message was playing on a loop.
有车流，路上排着长长的车队。就在这时，电力中断了。苏珊打开汽车收音机，以便在他们准备离开时能继续听广播。那是她第一次意识到并注意到，我是8点钟打开收音机的。现在已经是11点15分了。播放的还是同一条消息。1区、5区、12区、15区请撤离。请等待其他区域的通知。紧急广播一直在循环播放。
They've abandoned the emergency station. That cannot be good. That can't be good. So then I said, OK, honey, we got to get out of here. They pulled the car out of the driveway and went absolutely nowhere. It was bumper to bumper traffic. Like we got maybe 500 yards in 45 minutes,
他们已经放弃了紧急广播电台。这绝对不是什么好兆头。这可不妙。于是我说：“好了，亲爱的，我们得离开这里了。”他们把车从车道上开出去，结果根本动弹不得。车子一辆挨着一辆，动弹不得。就像我们在45分钟内只挪了大概500码，
and now it's noon, it's black as night. You can see the glow of the fire, you know, off in the distance. There was no way to know if the traffic was going to improve. And so Susan and John Michael ducked into a church parking lot to figure out a plan. Susan actually had a brochure from the fire training that she had gone to a couple of weeks before, and she pulled it out. It was like they had a checklist.
现在已经是中午了，天黑得像黑夜一样。你能看到远处大火的光芒。根本无法知道交通状况会不会变好。于是苏珊和约翰·迈克尔把车拐进了一个教堂停车场，商量对策。苏珊随身带着几周前参加消防培训时拿到的宣传册，她把它拿了出来。上面就像有一份检查清单。
Do this, do this, do that, do that. I'm just struck by the fact that you're in the midst of the biggest crisis of your life and you're reading a brochure. I know, because we had just gone to the workshop, right? Except the brochure said that if they couldn't get out, they should lie on the ground, put a blanket over their head, and shelter in place. Susan was not particularly excited about this idea.
做这个，做这个，做那个，做那个。我只是对一件事感到震惊：你正身处一生中最大的危机中，而你却在读宣传册。我知道，因为我们刚刚去过研讨会嘛！不过宣传册上说，如果他们逃不出去，就应该趴在地上，用毯子盖住头，就地避难。苏珊对这个主意可不怎么感冒。
It seemed like such a last resort kind of move. I looked at John Michael's out, are we going to do this? He said, no. I said, OK, what are we going to do? There was no way to get anywhere in a car, but John Michael thought he knew a back trail through the woods that would take them to a larger parking lot that would feel a lot safer. And so we just took what we could on our backs, took the dog, forgot my phone.
这看起来实在是一种万不得已的举动。我看着约翰·迈克尔，问：“我们要这么做吗？”他说：“不。”我说：“好吧，那我们怎么办？”开车去哪儿都不可能了，但约翰·迈克尔觉得自己知道一条穿过树林的后山小路，可以带他们到一个感觉安全得多的更大停车场。于是我们只背了能拿的东西，带上了狗，忘了拿手机。
He took his ukulele so we'd have something to do. And we walked down the road to cut through the woods to get over to a holiday market parking lot. And the only time I think really that we were afraid was as we were going through that woods, we didn't know if there was gonna be fire on the other side or if we could get trapped in the woods by fire, we didn't know if there's gonna be fire on the other side or what the you know if we could get trapped in the woods by fire we didn't know so we stopped and I said honey this is what all our spiritual practice has
他带了他的尤克里里琴，这样我们还能有点事干。我们沿着路走，穿过树林去假日市场（holiday market）的停车场。我想我们唯一一次真正感到害怕的时候，就是穿过那片树林的时候，我们不知道树林那边是不是也有火，或者我们会不会被大火困在树林里，我们不知道树林那边是不是会有火，或者……你知道的，我们会不会被大火困在树林里，我们不知道。所以我们停下来，我说：“亲爱的，这就是我们所有灵修的意义所在，这是我们的最后一天了，回头在另一边见。”
been about this is our last day now I'll see you on the other side well Susan and John Michael were hiking through the woods crystal was battling traffic on the one road off the ridge. The news of the fire had come earlier at her trailer park. A police officer showed up around 11 in the morning and just told them to get the hell out of there. The sheriffs came through there saying, get out of here. mandatory evacuation to all of paradise. Get people moving now. Get down to Chico or get down to wherever you can get to. Doesn't matter which roads you take, just go.
就在苏珊和约翰·迈克尔在树林里跋涉时，克里斯塔尔正在下山唯一的公路上与车流艰难搏斗。火灾的消息更早传到了她的房车公园。上午11点左右，一名警察赶到，告诉他们赶紧离开那儿。治安官穿梭其间喊着：“离开这里。天堂镇全员强制疏散。让大家现在就动起来。去奇科，或者去任何你能去的地方。走哪条路都行，只要走就行。”
Crystal and a group of neighbors piled into an old RV and headed down the Skyway, the main road out of town. We've got the fire coming downtown Skyway, where it's Skyway and Moppy. We've got the road completely blocked. Somebody needs to be able to open it up and get people out of here. The whole ride out of there just seemed like we're in the towering inferno. The sky was nothing but flames all around us.
克里斯塔尔和一群邻居挤进了一辆老旧房车，顺着城里的主干道天路（Skyway）往山下开。我们在天路市区、天路和莫皮（Moppy）交界处遇到了大火。道路完全被堵死了。必须有人把路打开，让人们离开这里。逃离那里的整个车程感觉就像身处《火烧云霄》里。天空四周除了火焰什么都没有。
It's like these big old fireballs just shooting everywhere. There just weren't enough roads for everyone up there to evacuate all at once. But after several hours stuck in the most terrifying traffic jam of her life, Crystal finally made it down off the ridge safely. Oh my god, I can't believe we're alive. Back up the hill, Susan and John Michael somehow managed to find a safe path through the woods,
就像巨大的火球到处乱射。那里根本没有足够的道路供山上的所有人同时疏散。但在经历了人生中最恐怖的几个小时交通大堵塞后，克里斯塔尔终于安全逃下了山脊。哦天哪，我不敢相信我们还活着。山顶上，苏珊和约翰·迈克尔不知怎么的，带着约翰·迈克尔的尤克里里琴，在树林里找到了一条安全的路，
carrying John Michael's ukulele. And they ended up in a different parking lot, outside of a holiday market, where they were met by a bunch of Cal Fire officials. We went up to one of them and said, what do we do? And he said, stay here, you'll be safe here. This parking lot was safer than the last one. And visually, it was kind of shielded from the worst of the fire.
他们最后来到了另一个停车场，在假日市场外面，那里有一群加州消防局（Cal Fire）的官员。我们走到其中一个人面前问：“我们该怎么办？”他说：“留在这里，在这里是安全的。”这个停车场比上一个安全。而且从视线上看，它在一定程度上挡住了最猛烈的火势。
And so as the afternoon dragged on, Susan and John Michael didn't really have a sense for how bad things had gotten. At the end of the day, the county sheriffs came and picked them up. Can we take you down to Chico, ma'am? And I was like, you know, we'd like to just go back to our house if it's all the same to you.
因此，随着下午的流逝，苏珊和约翰·迈克尔并没有真正意识到情况到底变得有多糟糕。到了傍晚，县治安官开车来接他们。女士，我们能带您去奇科吗？我说，你知道的，如果对你们来说都一样的话，我们只想回我们的房子。
And they're like, they looked at me like I was out of my mind and say, no, there's fire everywhere, ma'am. I said, really? Okay. So I thought, all right, they may have to do this, you know, so we get in the car with them and not two blocks away. Every direction that you look is flames. Just everything. You look all the way down this way.
他们看着我，就像看一个疯子一样，说：“不行，女士，到处都是火。”我说：“真的吗？好吧。”我想，好吧，他们可能必须这么做，所以我们上了他们的车，结果还没开出两个街区。放眼望去，各个方向全都是火焰。到处都是。你往那个方向一直看。
Nothing. It's like a disaster set from a movie. So many people evoke movies when they're trying to describe what it feels like to be in the middle of a disaster like the Camp Fire. I think it's because there's really nothing from day-to-day life that could possibly serve as a point of comparison. The fire was just too intense for normal language, too otherworldly. And the level of destruction really was the stuff of alien invasions. Nearly the entire town was incinerated that day, turned to white ash.
什么都没有。就像电影里的灾难布景。许多人在试图描述身处像坎普大火这样的灾难中心是什么感觉时，都会联想到电影。我想这是因为日常生活中真的没有什么东西可以拿来作对比。火势实在太猛烈了，超出了寻常语言的描述，仿佛来自另一个世界。而破坏的程度确实堪称外星人入侵。那天，几乎整个小镇都被烧成了灰烬，化为白色的骨灰。
Susan and John Michael lost their home and everything in it. Somehow Susan's car, which they abandoned at that first church parking lot, survived. Although one side of it got all melty. She never got it fixed, still drives it around like a badge of honor. Crystal also lost most of her possessions that day. The trailer park where she lived and worked partially burned during the fire. And she was so traumatized by her experiences that she never wanted to go up on the ridge again. All three of them though, were lucky to make it out alive. 85 people died in the campfire. But even before the extent of that tragedy was fully understood, it was clear that another
苏珊和约翰·迈克尔失去了他们的家以及里面的一切。不知怎的，苏珊的车——他们遗弃在第一个教堂停车场的车——竟然幸存了下来。尽管车身的一侧被烤得融化了。她一直没去修理它，到现在还开着它到处跑，就像一枚荣誉勋章。克里斯塔尔那天也失去了大部分财产。她生活和工作的房车公园在火灾中部分被烧毁。她的经历给她留下了巨大的心理创伤，以至于她再也不想去山脊上了。不过，他们三人总算活着逃了出来。坎普大火夺去了85人的生命。但甚至在这场悲剧的严重程度被完全认知之前，人们就已经清楚地看到，另一场灾难正在拉开序幕。
disaster was starting to unfold. One that would impact Susan and Crystal in very different ways. That's coming up after the break. The campfire displaced roughly 50,000 people from the ridge above Chico. And over time, the diaspora of fire survivors fanned out across the country. People moved to be closer to family or further away from their own trauma. Researchers at Chico State have found fire survivors in all 50 states, but the majority of people
这场灾难将以非常不同的方式影响苏珊和克里斯塔尔。中场休息后即将播出。坎普大火导致奇科上方山脊大约50,000人流离失所。随着时间的推移，火灾幸存者的散居地遍布全国。人们搬家是为了离家人更近，或者为了远离他们自己的创伤。奇科州立大学的研究人员在全美50个州都发现了火灾幸存者的踪迹，但大多数人
did not go very far. At least 15,000 of them ended up down the hill in Chico, a town that was struggling to keep its existing population fully housed, grew by more than 15% in one day. You know, we would have never imagined ourselves to be walking down the street in Chico without a place to go.
并没有走太远。其中至少有15,000人最终来到了山下的奇科——这座原本就难以妥善安置现有居民的小镇，在一天之内人口增长了15%以上。你知道，我们做梦也想不到自己会流落街头，走在奇科的街道上。
Hotels booked up immediately. It was hard to get a room in Sacramento, a city of half a million people that's 90 miles away. And so Susan and John Michael found themselves in a McDonald's, scrolling through their contact lists. I was like, okay, what friends are gonna take us in? You know, who can we ask this of? Sometimes when I think about the fire,
酒店瞬间爆满。要在90英里外拥有50万人口的萨克拉门托（Sacramento）找个房间都很难。于是苏珊和约翰·迈克尔发现自己坐在一家麦当劳里，翻看着手机里的通讯录。我想，好吧，有哪些朋友会收留我们呢？你知道，我们可以向谁开口求助？有时当我想到这场大火时，
I think about the metaphor of a staircase. Everyone who was up on the ridge that day fell down the stairs. But where you ended up depended a lot on what stair you started on. For people at the top, they landed somewhere in the middle. But for a lot of people who were already struggling with housing before the fire, they bottomed out. Susan and Crystal had very different trajectories in the aftermath of the fire, they bottomed out. Susan and Crystal had very different trajectories in the aftermath of the fire,
我就会想到楼梯的比喻。那天在山脊上的每个人都从楼梯上摔了下来。但你最终落在哪一级，很大程度上取决于你最初站在哪一级。对于站在顶端的人来说，他们落在了中间某个位置。但对于许多在火灾前就已经在为住房苦苦挣扎的人来说，他们跌入了谷底。火灾过后，苏珊和克里斯塔尔的人生轨迹截然不同，她们跌入了谷底。火灾过后，苏珊和克里斯塔尔的人生轨迹截然不同，
and their paths diverged right away, as they both had to figure out where they were gonna sleep that night. One of the biggest factors working in Susan and John Michael's favor was that they just had a lot of friends in Chico, including one crucial friend named Athena. And when we called her, she said,
她们的道路从一开始就分道扬镳了，因为她们都必须想方设法解决当晚的住宿问题。对苏珊和约翰·迈克尔有利的最大因素之一，就是他们在奇科有很多朋友，其中包括一位至关重要的朋友，名叫雅典娜（Athena）。当我们给她打电话时，她说：
oh my God, I've been calling you for hours. Thank God you got in touch with me. How are you guys doing? Come to the house right away. Come, you're going to stay here. This is where you're going to stay. Taking on a temporary housemate from Paradise was a totally normal thing in Chico
接纳一个来自天堂镇的临时室友是一件再正常不过的事。起初，这座城市似乎凭借着纯粹的慷慨膨胀起来，尽可能多地塞进新面孔。火灾幸存者睡在朋友的沙发上，在表亲的前院扎营。有些人甚至借宿在陌生人家里。所以发生的情况是，好吧，一开始每个人都在这里，倾泻而出的同理心，每个人都能理解。
in the aftermath of the fire. At first, it was as if the town swelled through sheer generosity to cram in as many new people as it could. Fire survivors slept on friends' couches and camped in cousins' front yards. Some people even stayed with strangers. So what happened was, is, okay, everyone's here initially, great outpouring of compassion, everyone understands.
这里又是埃德·迈耶，当时的比尤特县住房管理局局长。如果你愿意，你可以走进镇上的任何一家商店，把购物车装满然后走出去，根本不会有人过问。奇科的人民并没有要求数千名新邻居的到来。然而在早期，你在城市的各个角落都能感受到善意，甚至在沃尔玛也是如此。大火刚过后的头几天，许多流离失所的人最终聚集在沃尔玛的停车场里，而这里恰好就在
Here's Ed Mayer again, who ran the Butte County Housing Authority at the time. If you were inclined, you could walk into any store in town, fill up your grocery basket and walk out and no one would ask a question. The people of Chico did not ask for thousands of new neighbors. And yet early on, you could find kindness wherever you looked in the city, even at the Walmart. In the early days right after the fire, a lot of displaced people ended up in the Walmart parking lot, which just so happens to be right across the street
住房管理局埃德办公室的马路对面。对，就在我们办公室马路对面，这里有个沃尔玛，沃尔玛旁边大约有一块10英亩的空地。灾难发生的那天，第二天一早醒来，整个这块空地，还有沃尔玛的停车场，全都被帐篷、房车、拖车和露营车塞得满满当当。
from Ed's office at the Housing Authority. Yeah, right across the street here we have the Walmart, and right next to our Walmart, I think it's about a 10-acre parcel that's vacant. And the day of the disaster, that next morning, woke up, there was that whole parcel, and the Walmart parking lot was jam-packed, full of tents and trailers and RVs and campers.
哦天哪，我找你们好几个小时了。谢天谢地你们联系我了。你们怎么样？马上来家里。来吧，你们就住这儿。这就是你们要住的地方。在火灾过后的奇科，
The Walmart Tent City became a clearinghouse for donations. Well, we got you all covered. In this video taken during the first week, you can see piles of toilet paper, blankets, clothing and food, mostly donated by people in and around Chico. We have our own Walmart outside of Walmart. This is all what people in the community brought and dropped off. And those donations were important because a lot of people had nothing, including Crystal. After finally making it to Chico, her first stop was at a church where she was given a
沃尔玛帐篷城成了捐赠物资的中转站。好了，我们都为你们准备好了。在这段拍摄于第一周的视频中，你可以看到堆积如山的卫生纸、毯子、衣物和食物，大部分是由奇科本地及周边居民捐赠的。我们在沃尔玛外面也有了自己的“沃尔玛”。这些都是社区里的人们带来并放下。这些捐赠至关重要，因为很多人一无所有，包括克里斯塔尔。在历经艰辛到达奇科后，她的第一站是一家教堂，在那里她得到了一顿
free meal. She was with her teenage son. We'd sit there and look at each other and think, how are we going to do this? How are we going to make money to get clothes? Because we had nothing anymore. Unlike Susan and John Michael, Crystal didn't really have anyone in Chico she could stay with. And so she and her son got on a bus that took them
免费的饭菜。她和十几岁的儿子在一起。我们坐在那里看着对方，心想，我们该怎么熬过去？怎么赚钱买衣服？因为我们已经一无所有了。与苏珊和约翰·迈克尔不同，克里斯塔尔在奇科真的没有什么可以投奔的人。于是她和儿子登上了一辆公交车，
to the fairgrounds in the nearby town of Gridley, where the Red Cross was setting up a temporary sanctioned campground. Luckily, donations were already piling up there too, and she was able to snag a free tent. I had my tent when I was out there in a tent, in what they call tent city. The Gridley Fairgrounds became a tent city run by the Red Cross and the kindness of strangers. People would come by and give us gift certificates and this and that, whatever, and everything was brand new. Nothing was used. Nothing. And to have all that new stuff, it just warmed up my heart. Call me a sap, but I think that people are mostly good.
前往附近格里德利镇（Gridley）的集市广场，红十字会（Red Cross）在那里建立了一个由官方批准的临时露营地。幸运的是，那里的捐赠物资也已经堆积如山，她成功弄到了一顶免费的帐篷。当我在帐篷里、在他们所谓的帐篷城时，我有了自己的帐篷。格里德利集市广场变成了一个由红十字会以及陌生人的善意维持的帐篷城。人们会顺路过来送给我们礼品券，这啊那啊，不管是什么，而且一切都是崭新的。没有一样是旧的。全都是新的。拥有所有这些崭新的东西，让我的心都暖了。你可以说我是个多愁善感的人，但我认为人们本质上都是善良的。
And in the aftermath of disasters, you often see all that goodness turned up to 11. But there are limits to how far individual acts of generosity will go towards solving a giant systemic problem like the one facing Chico. People can't couch surf forever, and unofficial tent cities don't tend to last.
在灾难过后，你经常会看到这种善意被开到最大。但个人善举在解决像奇科面临的这种巨大系统性问题时，也是有极限的。人们不可能永远借宿在别人的沙发上，非官方的帐篷城往往也不会长久。
In the end, the Walmart encampment only lasted a couple of weeks before it was closed down. And then in January, two months after the fire, the Red Cross closed up shop in Gridley. Crystal and everyone else there were told that they would also need to move on. Well, we were out there almost until the end when Red Cross picked up and left and just
最终，沃尔玛的露营地只维持了几个星期就被关闭了。接着在1月，也就是火灾发生两个月后，红十字会撤出了格里德利。克里斯塔尔和那里的所有人被告知，他们也需要搬走。好吧，我们几乎待到了最后，直到红十字会收拾东西离开，
weren't going to care for us out there anymore. So we all started packing up and leaving. After a disaster, it's hard to pinpoint the exact moment when people go from being temporarily displaced to just being homeless. But this might have been that moment for Crystal. I talked to a lot of social workers for this piece. There was an army of homeless service providers and disaster case managers in Chico who were trying as hard as they could
不再管我们在那里的死活了。于是我们都开始打包离开。灾难过后，很难准确指出人们是从哪个具体时刻开始，从“暂时流离失所”变成“彻底无家可归”的。但对克里斯塔尔来说，这或许就是那个时刻。为了这篇报道，我采访了许多社工。奇科有一大批无家可归者服务机构和灾难个案经理，他们竭尽全力
to find everyone a safe place to live. And they did help a lot of people. But a lot of people ended up on the streets too. Every year, homelessness advocates do what's called a point in time count, where they fan out across the city and survey all of the unhoused residents. They did the count that year in March, about four months after the fire, and the results were chilling. Homelessness had increased all throughout the city, and over a third of unhoused people
为每个人寻找一个安全的住处。他们的确帮助了很多人。但也有很多人最终流落街头。每年，无家可归者权益倡导者都会进行所谓的“全美无家可归者统计”（point in time count），他们散布到城市各处，调查所有无家可归的居民。他们在当年3月，也就是火灾发生大约四个月后进行了统计，结果令人不寒而栗。全市的无家可归现象都有所增加，而奇科超过三分之一的无家可归者
in Chico identified as campfire survivors. But the impacts of the disaster on the housing market were really just beginning. On the day of the fire, John Baird was glued to the TV. He's a real estate agent in Chico, and at a certain point, he started doing the mental math on what the disaster might mean for the real estate market. And then over the course of the next three days, the real estate market here in Chico was just bonkers. The influence of the fire would ripple throughout the entire Chico housing market and affect
都自认是坎普大火的幸存者。但灾难对住房市场的冲击其实才刚刚开始。火灾当天，约翰·拜尔德（John Baird）一直紧盯着电视。他是奇科的一名房地产经纪人，在某个时刻，他开始在脑海中计算这场灾难可能对房地产市场意味着什么。然后在接下来的三天里，奇科的房地产市场简直彻底疯狂了。火灾的影响将波及整个奇科的住房市场，并影响到
people at all income levels, even those at the very top. Paradise was not a wealthy community, but there were some people with means living up there. People who had enough cash on hand to just purchase a new house without waiting around for an insurance settlement on their old one. And this class of people started buying up homes in Chico immediately, like that day. It was just a mad dash to try to get homes. And yeah, it was surreal. You know, it was kind of a major daze
各个收入水平的人，甚至是处于最顶层的人。天堂镇并不是一个富裕的社区，但那里也住着一些有财力的人。这些人手头有足够的现金，可以直接购买新房，而无需等待他们旧房的保险理赔金结算。这类人立刻开始在奇科抢购房屋，就在那天。简直是一场疯狂的抢房大战。真的，太超现实了。你知道的，那一整天都有种迷迷糊糊的感觉，
during the entire day, kind of like, you could not believe this is happening. Do you remember receiving calls that day? Yeah, so I had just happened to list a home in Chico, a really nice home that had been on the market and calling calls that day? Campfire survivors. Oh every single one. Yeah, every single one of them were you know, I think we had around 165 homes on the market in Chico before that weekend And after the weekend, they were virtually all sold
就好像，你简直不敢相信这一切正在发生。你还记得那天接到电话吗？是的，我刚好在奇科挂牌了一套房子，一套非常不错的房子，已经在市场上挂牌了……接到那天的电话了吗？坎普大火的幸存者。哦，全都是。是的，全都是他们……你知道的，我觉得那个周末之前我们在奇科大约有165套房源在售，而那个周末过后，它们几乎全部售罄。
Housing prices in Chico spiked in the weeks following the fire and rents went up right along with them by the end of the year, Reelitter.com declared Chico, quote, the hottest real estate market in the country, a twisted designation given the circumstances. This was the housing landscape that beleaguered Campfire survivors were operating in as they tried to get back on their feet. Here's Susan Dobre again. Housing was just insane. Everybody was having a hard time finding a place. People had friends and stuff like that, but it was like, okay, where am I gonna live?
火灾后几周内，奇科的房价飙升，房租也随之水涨船高。到了年底，Realtor.com宣布奇科是“全美最火爆的房地产市场”，鉴于当时的具体情况，这是一个充满讽刺意味的称号。这就是深陷困境的坎普大火幸存者们试图东山再起时所面对的住房市场。再次有请苏珊·多布雷。住房情况简直太疯狂了。每个人都在为找地方住而发愁。人们虽然有朋友之类的关系，但情况就像是：好吧，我到底该住在哪里？
After weeks crashing with friends and then more time living in a different friend's rental, Susan and John Michael started looking for a home to buy. They had gotten their insurance settlement and were ready for their next move. They didn't want to rebuild in paradise, though. They wanted to stay in Chico. John Michael, in particular, he was working through a lot of PTSD from the fire, and being in Chico made him feel safe. He could ride his bike everywhere he needed to go, which was great because every time he got stuck in traffic, he felt like he was reliving the worst day of his life.
在朋友家借住几周，又在另一个朋友的出租屋里住了一段时间后，苏珊（Susan）和约翰·迈克尔（John Michael）开始寻找可以买下的房子。他们拿到了保险理赔金，准备开始下一步的生活。不过，他们并不想在“人间天堂”重建家园，而是想留在奇科（Chico）。尤其是约翰·迈克尔，他当时正饱受大火带来的严重创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）折磨，留在奇科让他感到安全。他可以骑自行车去任何想去的地方，这太棒了，因为每次陷入交通堵塞，他都觉得自己在重温人生中最糟糕的一天。
It doesn't matter where I'm at. If I get in gridlock anywhere on the planet, I'm not the same person. It's like, turn around, we're out of here. That's the kind of feeling. So it felt good to be in Chico. It felt safe, fire-wise. Did you actually, like, look at houses in Chico?
无论我在哪里都一样。如果我在地球上的任何地方遇上交通瘫痪，我都判若两人。那种感觉就像是：掉头，我们离开这里。就是这种感觉。所以待在奇科感觉很好。从防火的角度来看，这里让人感到安全。你们当时真的在奇科看房吗？
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We looked—we scoured for a year and a half. At one point, John Michael had his eye on this sweet little spot with fruit trees and a fireplace. But when he and Susan went to the open house, it became clear that it was going to sell for way above asking price.
哦，对。是的。是的。我们找过——我们搜寻了一年半。有一次，约翰·迈克尔看中了一处带果树和壁炉的可爱小地方。但当他和苏珊去参观开放日时，情况变得很明显：这栋房子的售价将远远高出标价。
By the time we walked up to the front porch, we heard that the bidding had already gone up above what we could handle. Outbid there on the spot that morning? Yeah, that happened a lot. That happened a lot. But it wasn't just fire survivors who had to struggle in the post-fire housing market.
等我们走到前廊时，听说竞标价已经超过了我们能承受的范围。那天早上就在现场出局了？是的，这种情况经常发生。这经常发生。但不仅仅是火灾幸存者在灾后住房市场上挣扎。
It was also really hard for renters in Chico because a lot of landlords took advantage of the situation and jacked up the rent or just sold their house to the highest desperate bidder. You have people, homeowners, that were like, oh, well, they're in a prime situation to sell their home now because people have insurance money to buy a new home. Great. I'm selling my home. This is Hillary Crosby, executive director of the organization Safe Space Chico.
奇科的租房者日子也非常艰难，因为许多房东利用这种情况大幅抬高租金，或者干脆把房子卖给出价最高的绝望竞标者。有些房东觉得，哦，好吧，他们现在处于出售房屋的绝佳时机，因为人们手里有保险金可以买新房。太好了。我要卖房了。这是奇科“安全空间”（Safe Space Chico）组织执行董事希拉里·克罗斯比（Hillary Crosby）。
She says that a lot of renters ended up getting kicked out when their landlords sold. And that only added to the number of people who were struggling on the streets of Chico. That is people we see on the street that had their housing sold out from underneath them because people saw an opportunity and I mean it is what it is but they took it and we are still in a housing crisis. And all of those people who got displaced because of price gouging and eviction, they didn't have many resources available to them. Ironically, those who lost their homes directly in the fire, they got more help. It wasn't always easy to access, but there were FEMA payouts and insurance and fire relief fundraisers, and eventually settlement money from PG&E, whose
她说，很多租房者最终因为房东卖房而被赶了出去。这只会增加在奇科街头苦苦挣扎的人数。这就是我们在街上看到的那些人，他们的住房被转手卖掉了，因为别人看到了商机，我的意思是既成事实，但他们确实抓住了机会，而我们仍然处于住房危机中。所有这些因为哄抬物价和驱逐而流离失所的人，他们没有多少可用资源。讽刺的是，那些在大火中直接失去家园的人反而得到了更多帮助。虽然获取这些帮助并不总是那么容易，但有联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）的救济金、保险、火灾救济募捐，最终还有来自太平洋天然气与电力公司（PG&E）的赔偿金，因为该公司
faulty equipment started the fire. But people who lost their homes indirectly, they didn't get any of that. And so when you say, were you impacted by the campfire? Well, that's a hard question to answer because if you lost your housing, you weren't in the fire, but your landlord sold your household from underneath you and now you can't find any place for you and your family. I feel that's disaster impacted,
的故障设备引发了这场大火。但是间接失去家园的人却没有得到任何这些东西。所以当你问，你受到坎普大火的影响了吗？嗯，这是一个很难回答的问题，因为如果你失去了住房，你虽然没在大火现场，但你的房东把你的住所从你脚下卖掉了，现在你找不到任何能容纳你和家人的地方。我觉得这也算受灾影响，
but are there any resources for you? Not necessarily. A year and a half after the campfire, there were still lots of survivors who didn't have a place to live, and many others who were struggling with the high rents and evictions that followed in the fire's wake.
但是有针对你们的资源吗？不一定。坎普大火过去一年半后，仍有大量幸存者没有住所，还有许多人仍在苦苦应对大火之后随之而来的高昂租金和驱逐潮。
All of that only added to the large population of people who were unhoused in Chico before the fire. But patience with all of the people on Chico's streets was starting to wear thin, and compassion towards those who were still struggling began to run out. Here's Ed Mayer again, the former director of the Butte County Housing Authority. — Similarly to news cycles, attention spans, you know, people just get burned out after a while. It's like, enough already, okay? I've dealt with the disaster. I'm—my life, I mean, get on with it. — But not everyone was able to just get on with it.
所有这一切，只会让大火之前奇科原本就庞大的无家可归人口雪上加霜。然而，人们对奇科街头所有这些人的耐性开始逐渐耗尽，对仍在苦苦挣扎的人的同情心也开始消磨殆尽。再次听到 Butte 县住房管理局前局长埃德·迈耶（Ed Mayer）的话。——就像新闻周期和注意力跨度一样，你知道的，人们在经历了一段时间后就会感到精疲力竭。这就好比，够了行吗？我已经处理过这场灾难了。我——我的生活，我是说，继续过下去吧。——但并不是每个人都能“继续过下去”。
Susan Dobre says that it was hard enough for her and John Michael to piece their lives back together after the fire. And they had lots of things working in their favor, a good insurance policy, lots of friends, each other. Many fire survivors didn't have all that support. I know many people in paradise that are just hanging on by their fingernails already,
苏珊·多布拉（Susan Dobre）说，大火过后，她和约翰·迈克尔要想把生活重新拼凑起来已经够难了。而且他们有很多有利条件：一份不错的保单、许多朋友、彼此相伴。许多火灾幸存者并没有获得所有这些支持。我知道天堂镇（Paradise）有许多人仅凭着微弱的力量苦苦支撑，
you know, and said something like this hits, I know many people in paradise that are just hanging on by their fingernails already, you know, and something like this hits, you know, it wipes them out, it sets them back years and years in their recovery from whatever it is they're recovering from. Frustration with the large numbers of unhoused people in Chico began to simmer. And then, during the early days of the pandemic, it bubbled over. The city stopped breaking up encampments during the COVID lockdown, and everyone I talked to agreed that the encampments grew larger and more chaotic during this period.
你知道的，当这样的事情发生时，我知道天堂镇有许多人仅凭着微弱力量苦苦支撑，你知道的，当发生这样的事时，你知道的，它彻底摧毁了他们，让他们从无论什么创伤中的恢复进程倒退了整整好几年。人们对奇科大量无家可归者的挫败感开始暗流涌动。然后，在大流行初期，这种情绪彻底爆发了。在新冠疫情封锁期间，市政府停止了清理露营地的行动，我交谈过的每个人都一致认为，在此期间，露营地变得更大、更混乱了。
Without garbage collection, the trash began to pile up, and a lot of people in Chico started getting very upset about the conditions inside their parks. Over time, you started to hear a new story getting told around town, that the people living in the parks were not fire survivors or even local to the area, but that they were coming to Chico from all over
由于没有垃圾清理服务，垃圾开始堆积如山，许多奇科居民开始对他们公园内部的状况感到非常不满。随着时间的推移，你在镇上开始听到一种新的说法，称住在公园里的人并不是火灾幸存者，甚至不是本地人，而是从各地涌入奇科
to take advantage of services. Here is City Councilman Sean Morgan in an interview with a local radio station. The narrative that these are people from Chico and they're people from paradise and they're down on their luck is absolutely, totally false. I'm just going to jump in here to say that this is one of the most common and pernicious myths about homelessness that local politicians love to repeat. That all of the unhoused people in their city are coming from somewhere else. And the stragglers that just came to Chico, which is the great majority of them, because
来利用各种社会服务的。这是市议员肖恩·摩根（Sean Morgan）在接受当地广播电台采访时的言论。关于这些人来自奇科、来自天堂镇而且只是运气不佳的说法，是绝对且完全错误的。我要在这里插一句，这是关于无家可归者最常见、也最恶毒的谣言之一，当地政客们非常喜欢重复这种说法。那就是他们城市里所有的无家可归者都是从别处来的。而那些刚来到奇科的流民，占了绝大多数，因为
it was convenient and it was easy and they heard somewhere I can get needles and drugs and healthcare and free camping. They need to go back where they came from. Unhoused people move around, just like everyone else. But researchers at UC San Francisco recently put out one of the most robust surveys on homelessness in California and found that 75% of unhoused people were living in the same county as when they last had a house. And Ed Maier says that the homeless point in time counts in Butte County have had similar findings. We've learned through our homeless point in time counts that these are our citizens.
这里方便、容易，而且他们听说某个地方可以弄到针头、毒品、医疗服务和免费露营。他们需要回到他们来的地方去。无家可归者会四处流动，就像其他任何人一样。但加州大学旧金山分校（UC San Francisco）的研究人员最近发布了加州关于无家可归问题最详尽的调查之一，发现 75% 的无家可归者所居住的县，正是他们最后一次拥有住房时所在的县。埃德·迈耶（Ed Maier）表示，比尤特县（Butte County）的无家可归者“特定时间点普查”（Point-in-Time Count）也得出了类似的结果。我们通过无家可归者特定时间点普查了解到，这些人就是我们的市民。
These are not people who've come from other places. These are ours. I wanna be really clear. The majority of people in these parks were not fire survivors. But all of them were trying to find a place to live in the middle of a county-wide housing crisis that had been deeply exacerbated by the fire. And also, some of them were fire survivors, including Crystal Johnson.
这些人不是从其他地方来的。这些人是我们的。我想明确一点。这些公园里的绝大多数人并不是火灾幸存者。但他们所有人都在全县范围内的住房危机中寻找住处，而这场危机已经被大火严重恶化了。而且，其中一些人确实是火灾幸存者，包括水晶·约翰逊（Crystal Johnson）。
Crystal was bouncing around a lot during this period. She found a free trailer on Facebook, which she parked behind a motel and lived in for a bit. Then she got a room in the motel for a while through a pandemic program, but that didn't last either. And eventually she found herself back on the streets, attracting unwanted attention. We didn't have a place to shower or get bathed up.
水晶在这期间四处颠沛流离。她在脸书（Facebook）上找到了一辆免费的拖车，把它停在一家汽车旅馆后面并在里面住了一段时间。后来，她通过一个大流行期间的项目在汽车旅馆里住了一段时间，但这也没有持续多久。最终，她发现自己再次流落街头，引来了不必要的关注。我们没有洗澡或清洁身体的地方。
And to not smell or have clean clothes or fresh water, they started turning an eye on us. Crystal says it felt like some people in Chico started seeing her in a very different light. No longer was she the victim of this horrible fire. Now she was the problem. Some people didn't even believe that she had lived up on the ridge at all. But I have plenty of proof and it doesn't matter what they think. After a while, people say,
无法除味，没有干净的衣服或淡水，他们开始对我们侧目而起。水晶说，感觉奇科的一些人用一种截然不同的眼光看待她。她不再是那场可怕大火的受害者。现在她成了问题本身。有些人甚至不相信她曾在山脊上住过。但我有充分的证据，而且他们怎么想并不重要。过了一段时间，人们会说：
oh you're just another one of the local homeless people or transit people or no more campfire survivors. For Crystal, it seemed like this crucial chapter in the complicated story of how she ended up in this situation was being erased. And how can anybody judge another person when they haven't put their feet in their shoes and lived their life and what they've been through. Some people are quick to judge them, and it's not right. We've been out here because it's campfire. Period. But anger about the situation in the parks was powerful in Chico,
哦，你只是另一个本地无家可归者、流民，不再是什么坎普大火幸存者了。对水晶来说，关于她如何陷入这种境地的复杂故事中，这个至关重要的章节似乎正在被抹去。当人们没有设身处地去体验别人的生活、经历过别人所经历的一切时，又怎么能去评判另一个人呢？有些人急于对他们评判，这不对。我们流落到这里是因为坎普大火。就这么简单。但在公园情况引发的愤怒在奇科非常强烈，
and it coalesced into a political force. Conservative city council candidates started running on a promise to get tough on the encampments. The campaign resonated with a lot of people, and in November of 2020, the conservatives flipped the city council. And as soon as they got into power, they made good on their electoral promises by evicting
并凝聚成了一种政治力量。保守派市议员候选人以严厉打击露营地的承诺参加竞选。这场竞选引起了许多人的共鸣，2020年11月，保守派赢得了市议会的控制权。他们一上台，就开始兑现竞选承诺，驱逐了
a large encampment that had developed in one of the city's biggest parks. Chico PD, park rangers, and even city staff came in with bulldozers and cleared up the mess left by campers and homeless who've made this park their home. Evictions like this went on for months. Every time the police closed an encampment, a new one would pop up somewhere else, and the city just kept whacking the mole. Crystal remembers the feeling of getting moved again and again. We were always on the go.
在城市最大的公园之一形成的大型露营地。奇科警察局、公园巡逻队甚至市政府工作人员开着推土机进场，清理了露营者和将该公园当作家园的无家可归者留下的一片狼藉。这样的驱逐行动持续了好几个月。每当警方关闭一个露营地，另一个露营地就会在其他地方冒出来，而市政府就像打地鼠一样没完没了。水晶还记得一次又一次被迫搬迁的感觉。我们总是在奔波。
We just couldn't stay in one spot for too long. Otherwise cops would show up and we'd be told we got so many days or so many hours to move. Crystal was caught on a hamster wheel of displacement. And every time she got moved, she had the same question for the cops. Where were we supposed to go? They said, well, figure it out. Okay. I've been trying to figure it out. And it's not that easy. Eventually, the situation in Chico got so bad for unhoused folks that a group of attorneys filed a class action lawsuit against the city, arguing that Chico
我们就是不能在一个地方呆太久。否则警察就会出现，告诉我们只有几天或几个小时的时间搬走。水晶陷入了流离失所的仓鼠滚轮中。每一次被迫搬迁，她都会对警察提出同一个问题：我们到底该去哪里？他们说，好吧，自己想办法。好吧。我一直在试图想办法。但这并不容易。最终，奇科无家可归者的处境变得如此糟糕，以至于一群律师对市政府提起了集体诉讼，辩称奇科
could not legally evict people from public space if they had nowhere else to go. And a federal judge sided with the unhoused. He put a permanent injunction on the city, ruling that Chico could no longer clear encampments unless it could provide people with a spot in a shelter. As part of a settlement agreement, the city agreed to build what they call the pallet shelter. If that sounds like the bare minimum of what counts as housing, that's because it kind of is. It's a collection of 177 extremely tiny modular homes made by a
如果无家可归者无处可去，就不能合法地将他们从公共空间驱逐出去。联邦法官站在了无家可归者一边。他对市政府下达了永久禁令，裁定奇科除非能为人们提供庇护所的床位，否则不得再清理露营地。作为和解协议的一部分，市政府同意建造他们所谓的“方舱庇护所”（pallet shelter）。如果这听起来像是住房标准的最低限度，那是因为它确实差不多就是。这是由一家名为
company called Pallet. And Crystal was one of the very first people offered a spot. Stuff just to make it feel like home. People have little messages too. Yeah. Last year, producer Sophie Coddner and I visited the Pallet Shelter, which is also known as Genesis. And Crystal showed Sophie her tiny, tiny house.
Pallet 的公司制造的 177 个极小的模块化房屋集合。而水晶是第一批获得入住名额的人之一。放一些东西让这里感觉像个家。人们也留下了小纸条。是的。去年，制作人苏菲·科德纳（Sophie Coddner）和我参观了方舱庇护所，它也被称为“创世纪”（Genesis）。水晶向苏菲展示了她那极小的房子。
It's a little messy out in front of my place right now though. This your spot? Yeah. The shelter is a series of white boxes, arranged in neat rows across a dusty lot, like little storage units. Each one is 64 square feet. Yeah, it's really, really small.
不过我门前现在有点乱。这是你的地方？对。这个庇护所是一排排整齐排列在尘土飞扬的空地上的白色方盒子，就像一个个小仓库。每个面积只有 64 平方英尺。对，真的非常非常小。
It's basically the size of a jail cell. Crystal and her son moved into the shelter the third day it was open. After being checked in and everything, we go to our pallets and they gave us a sleeping bag and a pillow and we walk in there and I just had all the weight that was on my shoulder just gone. It was gone. It was just a relief. The space was small, barely enough room for her,
它基本上就是一间监狱牢房的大小。庇护所开放的第三天，水晶和她的儿子就搬了进去。办完入住手续后，我们走到我们的方舱前，他们给了我们一个睡袋和一个枕头，我们走进去，压在我肩上的所有重担就这么消失了。全都没了。这真是一种解脱。空间很小，勉强够她一个人住，
let alone her son. But she finally had a door she could close. By this point, it had been more than three years since Crystal had lost everything in the fire. More than three years of not knowing whether she'd be able to sleep at night. Not just because of the disaster, but because of how the system failed in its wake. She was exhausted. I crawled up there and just laid down just to see what it'd feel like and see if it
更不用说她的儿子了。但她终于有了一扇可以关上的门。到这个时候，距离水晶在大火中失去一切已经过去三年多了。三年多来，她一直不知道自己晚上是否能睡个安稳觉。不仅是因为这场灾难，还因为这个系统在灾后未能发挥作用。她筋疲力尽。我爬上去躺下，只是想感受一下这是什么感觉，看看它
was comfortable or not. I actually went right out. I just went right to sleep. I was so comfortable. The pallet shelter is run by the Jesus Center, a soup kitchen in town. There's a little office in the back with a team of friendly caseworkers who seem to know every resident by name. The shelter has been widely celebrated as a creative solution to Chico's problems.
舒不舒服。我实际上马上就睡着了。我直接就睡着了。太舒服了。方舱庇护所由镇上的一家名为“耶稣中心”（Jesus Center）的救济厨房运营。后面有一个小办公室，里面有一支友好的个案工作团队，他们似乎能叫出每一位居民的名字。这个庇护所被广泛誉为解决奇科问题的一个创造性方案。
But Ed Maier says that it's not getting to the root of the matter, which is the lack of housing. I simply say it this way, if I wanted to put every homeless person in a house, they don't exist. And that's the bottom line. Chico faces many of the same obstacles to building affordable housing as other cities in the country. Many of the residential neighborhoods are zoned exclusively for single-family homes.
但埃德·迈耶（Ed Mayer）表示，这并没有触及问题的根源，也就是住房短缺。我是这么简单说的：如果我想把每一个无家可归的人都安置进房子里，这些房子根本不存在。这就是底线。奇科在建设保障性住房方面面临着与该国其他城市相同的许多障碍。许多住宅区被划定为仅限单户住宅。
And every time someone tries to build a new apartment building, there's fierce opposition from local NIMBYs. But Ed is also feeling more hopeful than he has in years. After the Campfire, a lot of federal funding poured into Butte County for affordable housing. When I spoke to Ed, he said that there were 3,000 new units in the pipeline. It's a drop in, he said that there were 3,000 new units in the pipeline. It's a drop in the bucket compared to what's needed. But to Ed, who has watched the county
而且每当有人试图建造新的公寓楼时，都会遭到当地“邻避主义者”（NIMBYs）的激烈反对。但埃德也感到比多年来更有希望。坎普大火之后，大量联邦资金涌入比尤特县用于建设保障性住房。我和埃德交谈时，他说有 3,000 套新住房正在筹备中。这只是杯水车薪，他说有 3,000 套新住房正在筹备中。与实际需求相比，这只是杯水车薪。但对埃德来说，他看着这个县
struggle to build housing for decades, it doesn't feel that way. It's like a tsunami of affordable housing units. So with one development, we took 41 households off the street. Are you getting some campfire survivors in that? Oh yes, absolutely. Yeah, we see campfire survivors in everything we do. We see them all the time. When Crystal Johnson first got to the Pallet Shelter, she met with a case manager and got
几十年来一直在为建造住房而苦苦挣扎，感觉却并非如此。这就像是一场保障性住房的海啸。因此，通过一个开发项目，我们就把 41 户家庭带离了街头。你们其中有火灾幸存者吗？哦，是的，当然。是的，我们在我们做的所有事情中都能看到火灾幸存者。我们随时都能看到他们。水晶·约翰逊刚到方舱庇护所时，她见了一位个案经理，并被
put on a wait list for some of the new apartments being developed by the housing authority. I want stability, I need stability. I have things I've got to get taken care of and I can't do that without permanent housing. So it's like really urgent that it happens. really urgent that it happens. — Crystal has now been at the pallet shelter for over two years. But it's unclear how much longer she'll be able to stay. A recent ruling by the U.S. Supreme Court gave city governments throughout the country a lot more power to break up encampments without providing alternative shelter. How that will impact the pallet shelter and the city of Chico's homelessness policies more broadly
列入了住房管理局正在开发的一些新公寓的等待名单中。我想要稳定，我需要稳定。我有一些事情必须处理，没有永久住房我是做不到这一点的。所以这真的非常紧急，必须发生。真的非常紧急，必须发生。——水晶现在已经在方舱庇护所住了两年多了。但目前还不清楚她还能住多久。美国最高法院最近的一项裁决赋予了全国各地的市政府更大的权力，可以在不提供替代庇护所的情况下驱逐露营地。这将如何影响方舱庇护所以及奇科市更广泛的无家可归者政策，
is an active ongoing story. But whatever happens, Crystal is just hoping to find a permanent place to live, where she can start to put this whole chapter behind her. A chapter that she memorialized with the most Northern California tattoo of all time. It's a message to the company that sparked the fire. Wait, will you describe that? I'd say it's Mickey Mouse's hand in tie-dye with the middle finger up showing the birdie, and it says PG Neon in the middle finger up showing the birdie, and it says PG&E in the middle finger. So you got a tattoo to say, f*** PG&E.
这是一个正在发展中的事件。但无论发生什么，水晶只希望能找到一个永久的住所，在那里她可以把这整段历史抛在脑后。她用最具北加州特色的纹身永远铭记了这段历史。这是给引发大火的公司的信息。等等，你能描述一下吗？我会说这是米老鼠的手，扎染图案，竖着中指比着国际友好手势，中间的手指上写着
Yeah, pretty much. Climate change is obviously not the singular cause of crystal situation. It's not even the singular cause of the campfire. But as the atmosphere heats up and the weather gets more volatile, it's exposing and exacerbating the vulnerabilities that already exist in our society, particularly when it comes to housing. In fact, I would argue that the climate crisis and the housing crisis are so deeply intertwined at this point that you almost can't distinguish one from the other. And one of the best ways to adapt to climate change is just to do a better job keeping
PG&E。所以你纹身是为了说：去他的 PG&E。——是的，差不多吧。气候变化显然不是导致水晶现状的唯一原因。它甚至不是引发坎普大火的唯一原因。但随着大气变暖和天气变得更加反复无常，它暴露并加剧了我们社会中原本就存在的脆弱性，特别是在住房方面。事实上，我认为气候危机和住房危机在这一点上已经紧密交织在一起，你几乎无法将两者区分开来。适应气候变化最好的方法之一，就是更好地确保
a roof over everyone's head. The point is, is people are getting displaced or hurt out there and we need to figure out a way to take care of them because these events are not going to stop happening and they seem to be increasing in frequency. In the past few years, there have been many more massive wildfires in Butte County, like the Bear Fire and the Dixie Fire. And while I record this, the hills above Chico are on fire yet again, as the park fire burns through hundreds of thousands of acres northwest of Paradise. And every
每个人都有瓦遮头。关键在于，人们在那里流离失所或受到伤害，我们需要想办法照顾他们，因为这些事件不会停止发生，而且它们的发生频率似乎在增加。在过去的几年里，比尤特县发生了许多更多的大规模野火，比如熊灾（Bear Fire）和迪克西大火（Dixie Fire）。在我录制这段音频时，奇科上方的群山再次燃起大火，公园大火（Park Fire）正在天堂镇西北部烧毁数十万英亩的土地。每一次
time one of these big fires displaces a lot of people, some of them end up in Chico, where there still isn't enough housing. So we just have these disenfranchised, displaced people that are still here getting beat up more and more and they're not going anywhere. Nowhere is truly safe from climate change. But some places are safer than others. And when those places don't build enough affordable housing, it can create a vicious cycle where people get priced out of relative safety and into the path of
这些大火导致大量人员流离失所时，其中一些人最终会来到奇科，而这里依然没有足够的住房。所以我们只有这些被剥夺权利、流离失所的人仍然留在这里，遭受着越来越多的打击，而且他们无处可去。没有任何地方能真正免受气候变化的威胁。但有些地方比其他地方更安全。当这些地方没有建设足够的保障性住房时，就会产生一个恶性循环：人们因为高昂的房价被迫离开相对安全的地方，卷入
climate disasters like wildfires. And then, when a disaster predictably happens, there's nowhere for people to go. And so they end up on the streets. Or back in harm's way. Yeah, I'm a slow walker up this hill. Yeah, let's take our time. Let's definitely take our time. Yeah, look at just how green everything is.
野火等气候灾害的路径中。然后，当地震或灾难按预期发生时，人们无处可去。于是他们最终流落街头。或者重新陷入险境。是的，我爬这山坡走得挺慢的。对，我们慢慢来。我们绝对要慢慢来。对，你看周围一切是多么翠绿。
And I imagine it gets even greener. Emerald green everywhere. Yeah. After years of searching for a house and getting outbid at every turn, Susan and John Michael finally found a place in Butte Valley, about 15 miles southeast of Chico. It's a cozy little ranch house at the bottom of a grassy hill dotted with oak trees.
我想这里会变得更绿。到处都是翡翠般的绿。是的。经过多年的寻房和每次竞标失败后，苏珊和约翰·迈克尔终于在奇科东南约 15 英里处的比尤特谷（Butte Valley）找到了一处住所。这是一栋舒适的小牧场住宅，位于长满橡树的草地山坡底部。
I visited them in the middle of a drizzly week in early December. And as we hiked up the hill, I kept thinking, this place is amazing. I would love to live here. It's so beautiful. It's really so incredibly beautiful. It's just awesome. I just love it. I love the cool weather, the wetness.
我在 12 月初一个细雨蒙蒙的日子拜访了他们。当我们爬上山坡时，我一直在想，这个地方太棒了。我很想住在这里。太美了。真的是难以置信的美。简直太棒了。我太喜欢了。我喜欢这凉爽的天气，这湿润的空气。
Yeah, right. It's so moist and verdant. But if you've spent any time in California, you know that emerald green doesn't last. At the end of May, this is all going to be brown, yellow grass, all the way till October, end of October. Susan and John Michael got burnt out of paradise, only to end up back in fire country. John Michael wasn't that excited about this house at first. Remember, he wanted to live in Chico where he felt safe,
对，没错。如此湿润而苍翠。但在加州待过一段时间的人都知道，这种翠绿色是不会持久的。到五月底，这里全都会变成棕色、黄色的草，一直持续到十月底，十月底结束。苏珊和约翰·迈克尔从天堂镇被大火烧了出来，结果却又回到了火灾易发区。起初约翰·迈克尔对这栋房子并不是那么兴奋。记住，他想住在让他感到安全的奇科，
but they just couldn't find a house they could afford there. And they also didn't want to move too far away from all of the friends who had helped them get through these difficult years. And so this is where they ended up. So in the beginning I was thinking, man, I don't want to be here. Then I would love, you know, then we'd see the stars at night and how beautiful this place is.
但他们就是在那儿找不到买得起的房子。而且他们也不想搬得离那些帮助他们度过这些艰难岁所以他们最终落脚在了这里。所以一开始我在想，天哪，我不想呆在这里。然后我就会爱上，你知道的，然后我们晚上会看到繁星，看到这个地方有多美。
I went back and forth and back and forth. In the end, it was one conversation with Susan that convinced him to give this place a shot. Susan told me, honey, if we can't do this, then we can't do this. So she assured me that if, you know, we reach a point where we can't live here because it is really too dangerous,
我的内心一直在动摇。最终，是与苏珊的一次对话说服他给这个地方一个机会。苏珊对我说，亲爱的，如果我们做不到这一点，那我们就真的做不到。所以她向我保证，如果，你知道的，我们到了无法住在这里的地步，因为这里确实太危险了，
then we'll just leave. So she told me that, and that made me feel more at ease, more safe. Little by little, the two of them She told me that, and that made me feel more at ease, more safe. Little by little, the two of them have been transforming the property. They planted gardens and orchards, and then set about trying to make the house as fire-resistant as they could. John Michael installed a fire suppression system, and put on a new, state-of-the-art roof.
那我们就离开。所以她告诉了我这些，这让我感到更安心、更安全。他们两个一点一点地一直在改造这处房产。他们种植了花园和果园，然后着手尽其所能让房子具备防火性能。约翰·迈克尔安装了灭火系统，并换上了全新的现代化屋顶。
And against his own aesthetic judgment, he covered up the beautiful old redwood siding with cement paneling. It took time and money, but he's feeling more at ease. So it took me over a year, a couple of years, to feel that feeling like we can be here and we'll be okay. Because the fire's coming, just a matter of time. Next time on Not Built For This,
出于他自身的审美判断，他用水泥板遮住了美丽的老红木护墙板。这需要时间和金钱，但他感觉更安心了。所以花了我一年多的时间，好几年，才找到那种我们可以待在这里并且会没事的安心感。因为大火还会来，这只是时间问题。下一期《不该为此而建》节目，
all across the country there is an economic force that is threatening to drive people away from areas of extreme climate risk. Insurance. The first policy we got was $2,400. The second year it went up to $3,000. The third year they wanted $7,600 almost. In recent years, insurance rates have skyrocketed as companies try to cover increased losses due to climate change.
全国各地都有一股经济力量，正威胁着将人们驱离极端气候风险区。那就是保险。我们买的第一份保单是 2,400 美元。第二年涨到了 3,000 美元。第三年他们要价将近 7,600 美元。近年来，随着公司试图弥补气候变化带来的不断增加的损失，保险费率急剧飙升。
And almost nowhere is that more true than in southwest Florida. Everyone's having insurance issues and insurance has become a nightmare in Florida all the way around. It once seemed like nothing could stop the Florida real estate machine. But rising insurance rates are threatening to put a lot of Floridians financially underwater, long before their houses are swallowed by the sea. When we're stormed like that, I'm out. You sell this damn own house, we're leaving. This episode of Not Built For This was reported and produced by me, Emmett Fitzgerald, with additional reporting by producer Sophie Cotner.
几乎没有哪个地方比美国西南部的佛罗里达州更能体现这一点。每个人都有保险问题，保险已经成为佛罗里达州方方面面的噩梦。曾经似乎没有什么能阻挡佛罗里达州的房地产机器。但不断上涨的保险费率正威胁着让许多佛罗里达人在他们的房子被大海吞噬之前，在经济上率先陷入困境。当遇到这样的风暴时，我就要撤了。你把这该死的房子卖了吧，我们要搬走了。本期《不该为此而建》由我，埃姆特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）采访并制作，制作人苏菲·科德纳（Sophie Cotner）协助采访。
The rest of the Not Built For This team is producer Jason DeLeon and managing editor Delaney Hall. Further invaluable editing from Christopher Johnson, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, and the one and only Roman Mars. Mix and sound design by Martin Gonzalez. Theme and original music by George Langford from Actual Magic, with additional music by Swan Rayal. Fact checking by Sona Avakian.
《不该为此而建》团队的其他成员包括制作人杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）和执行主编德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）。克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）以及独一无二的罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）提供了宝贵的编辑意见。混音和声音设计由马丁·加利扎（Martin Gonzalez）负责。主题曲和原创音乐由来自 Actual Magic 的乔治·兰福德（George Langford）创作，斯旺·拉耶尔（Swan Rayal）提供额外音乐。事实核查由索娜·阿瓦基安（Sona Avakian）负责。
Series art by Aaron Rayel. Fact-checking by Sona Avakian. Series art by Aaron Nestor. A huge thank you to everyone who spoke with us for this story, especially Crystal Johnson, Susan Dobra, and John Michael's son. If you want to see a video of John Michael playing a song that he wrote about the fire, there is a link on our website. In addition to everyone you heard from, I also want to thank Kate Scow Smith, Jacqueline Chase, Mark Stehman, Addison Winslow, Bryce Goldstein, Laura Cuzzona, Bob Troush, Dan Joseph, Jessica Giannola, J Rose, Tony Dunn, Amber Abney Bass, and Sophia at the Pallet Shelter. Not Built For This is a six-part series from 99% Invisible.
系列艺术设计由亚伦·内斯特（Aaron Nestor）负责。特别感谢所有接受我们采访的人，尤其是水晶·约翰逊、苏珊·多布拉和约翰·迈克尔的儿子。如果你想观看约翰·迈克尔演奏他为大火创作的歌曲的视频，我们的网站上有链接。除了你听到的所有人之外，我还要感谢凯特·斯科-史密斯（Kate Scow Smith）、杰奎琳·蔡斯（Jacqueline Chase）、马克·斯特曼（Mark Stehman）、艾迪生·温斯洛（Addison Winslow）、布莱斯·戈尔斯坦（Bryce Goldstein）、劳拉·库佐纳（Laura Cuzzona）、鲍勃·特鲁什（Bob Troush）、丹·约瑟夫（Dan Joseph）、杰西卡·詹诺拉（Jessica Giannola）、J·罗斯（J Rose）、托尼·邓恩（Tony Dunn）、安贝尔·阿布尼·巴斯（Amber Abney Bass）以及方舱庇护所的索菲亚（Sophia）。《不该为此而建》是 99% Invisible 的六部分系列节目。
New episodes will be coming to you in the 99PI feed on Tuesdays and Fridays, wherever you get your podcasts. Kathy Tu is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is our digital director. The rest of the 99PI team includes Chris Berube, Vivian Ley, Lasha Madan, Gabriella Gladney, Jacob Maldonado Medina, and Nina Potuck. The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are a part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family. You can find 99% Invisible on all of the usual social media sites,
新单集将在每周二和周五发布到 99PI 的动态中，你可以在任何收听播客的地方找到它们。凯西·图（Kathy Tu）是我们的执行制作人。库尔特·科尔stad（Kurt Kolstad）是我们的数字总监。99PI 团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁布（Chris Berube）、薇薇安·莱（Vivian Ley）、拉沙·马丹（Lasha Madan）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriella Gladney）、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado Medina）和尼娜·波图克（Nina Potuck）。99% Invisible 的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）设计。我们是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站上找到 99% Invisible，
as well as our new Discord server. There's a link to that and every episode of 99PI and Not Built For This at 99pi.org. ["The Last of Us"] There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及我们的新 Discord 服务器。在 99pi.org 上可以找到指向该服务器以及 99PI 和《不该为此而建》每一集的链接。["The Last of Us"] 本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。